carrusel de las artes maría carolina
piña
[Música]
un gusto saludarles desde parís para
este nuevo número de carrusel de las
artes donde daremos una vuelta desde el
norte al sur de francia pasando por la
capital para ver la vibrante actualidad
cultural francesa
el cielo y los paisajes de normandía a
través del pincel del británico david
hockney la colorida obra de este artista
instalado en francia se expone en parís
a pesar de la pandemia descubriremos los
secretos del mítico jabón de marsella un
emblema y patrimonio cultural con varios
siglos de historia
el arte como instrumento de cohesión y
de diálogo ese es uno de los proyectos
puestos en marcha en las y tejos filos
de parís para acompañar a personas en
situación de vulnerabilidad y a 30 años
de su muerte recordaremos al prolífico y
muy polémico ser your guns book uno de
los niños más terribles de la canción
francesa
[Música]
en tiempos de pandemia los museos han
tenido que cerrar pero las galerías de
arte siguen abiertas al público y en la
galería a lo long de parís una
exposición titulada 'mi normandía exhibe
las obras llenas de luz y de color de
david hockney el famoso artista
británico vive en esa región francesa
desde hace dos años y la exposición
presenta cuadros inspirados en su nueva
tierra adoptiva un reportaje de axel
simon james ondrej que nos presenta
melissa barra
sus obras rompen récords de precio para
un artista vivo el británico david
hockney tiene una nueva musa la región
francesa de normandía donde se instaló
hace dos años antes de la pandemia job
se muere el director de la galería loro
y está muy contento vivió el
confinamiento como un regalo del cielo
sin visitas sin periodistas sin
interrupciones durante años se dedicó a
pintar a california y estaba harto de
ese cielo siempre azul luego volvió a
inglaterra a yorkshire hace una década y
pintó los paisajes ingleses aquí en
normandía encontró otra luz en francia
los museos siguen cerrados
entonces los amantes del arte han
recurrido a las galerías se tutea beso
al cielo todo es absolutamente esencial
como lo es mi negocio yo soy libre era
sin nosotros sin cultura no hay vida
en las paredes cuelgan dibujos y una
decena de pinturas inéditas evocan las
cuatro estaciones cada una parece más
colorida que la otra
sé que he estado trabajando mucho cuando
el ipad últimamente así que me interesó
y ahora veo que la pintura es real me
gustan sus colores su visión de la
naturaleza en la natura es alegre
agradable y es muy primaveral venimos a
ver sus obras para sentirnos mejor
para los amantes de david hockney es una
gran oportunidad de ver estas obras
juntas la popularidad del artista está
en aumento
todos estos cuadros se vendieron incluso
antes de que se inaugurara la exposición
[Música]
y del cielo de normandía vamos al sur de
francia para explorar los secretos del
bien ponderado jabón de marsella un
producto natural con varios siglos de
historia y que se sigue fabricando hoy
con una técnica ancestral la jabonería
más grande y antigua de la ciudad nos
abrió sus puertas
[Música]
y el jabón verde y su olor particular
son todo un símbolo de la ciudad de
marsella un patrimonio histórico e
industrial contenido en un cubo
emblemático que se fabrica aún hoy según
el método ancestral
[Música]
el jabón de marsella está íntimamente
ligado a la historia de esta ciudad hay
evidencias de que se comenzó a fabricar
a partir del siglo 13 es decir que desde
hace 800 años se descubrió cómo hacer
este tipo de jabón poco a poco se fue
convirtiendo en una de las principales
industrias de la ciudad hubo una época
de oro entre los siglos 17 y 20 a
principios de 1900 había casi 100
fábricas de jabón en marsella
y lo más importante no es el lugar sino
los ingredientes que se utilizan y el
proceso de fabricación del jabón de
marsella que es muy específico es lo que
garantiza la calidad final del producto
final
[Música]
el jabón de marsella auténtico debe
contener al menos 72 por ciento de
aceites vegetales exclusivamente agua
sal y soda cáustica el llamado
procedimiento marsellés consiste en
cinco etapas que comienzan hirviendo los
aceites en calderas gigantes una técnica
que mitchell bianconi aprendió de su
padre hasta convertirse él también el
maestro jabonero clase en copo en estas
calderas de 30.000 litros colocó 10
toneladas de aceite
hoy en día usamos vapor para hervir los
aceites junto a la soda cáustica se
forma entonces una pasta que hay que
cocinar durante una semana para obtener
el jabón este proceso químico se llama
saponificación luego se hacen varios
lavados para separar el exceso de sora y
por último pasamos a la liquidación para
obtener una fase cristalina lisa ella
crea la fei sólo líquido
si a patronato aquí no hay botones todo
es manual hay que saber escuchar el
hervor observarlo olerlo con el oído la
nariz y los ojos se cuando la pasta está
lista es así que se llega a ser un buen
jabonero es algo que se aprende por amor
por eso es un arte ancestral se posaba
que se hace esto
cómo
una vez fría la pasta de jabón es
moldeada en forma de barra cortada en
cubos y marcada en todas sus caras para
su comercialización
[Música]
hoy en día el jabón de marsella ha
evolucionado hacia otros formatos y
productos para la casa o jabones
perfumados en las familias francesas las
abuelitas compraban una barra de 4 kilos
a veces de mucho más y la cortaba en
diferentes pedazos para los diferentes
usos de casas de limpieza como del piso
lavar la ropa para uno mismo ducharse
lavarse y con el tiempo pasó la barra a
un cubo de este tamaño este es el
auténtico jabón de marsella tenemos una
gama perfumada con el perfume más
natural que hay en el mercado que es
hipoalergénico también utilizando la
lavanda la rosa
tenemos miel y almendras aromas
provenzales
[Música]
damos ahora un salto a la ciudad refugio
de parís un edificio de reinserción
social gestionado por la ong la salud el
ejército de salvación francés dos
artistas decidieron ayudar a sus
habitantes a contar sus historias a
través del retrato en un proyecto que se
llama alma humana el reportaje es de
mandi es manny y eloise me la han
presentado por mauricio la torre
decenas de vidas contadas en un solo
lugar
un retrato narra la historia de elección
un residente de 22 años en el centro del
colegio hay una llama y un pulmón
recuerdos de una mala experiencia cuando
era joven el equipo de a fraga estábamos
haciendo un concurso de llamas y yo
aspira en la mía así perdió un pulmón y
un día jugando dominó conocían lo ya
michelle con ellos hice mi retrato en el
aceite de profundidad
el proyecto empezó en filipinas and love
mesón y michel cam conocieron allí a
nelson un pescador que vivía en una casa
sobre palafitos quien se convirtió en el
modelo de su primer retrato los artistas
se quedaron bloqueados en parís por la
pandemia y eso los llevó a contar
experiencias difíciles control de casi
todas estas personas que viven al margen
de la sociedad pero también viven cerca
de nosotros en esta inmensa estructura
que es la cité de jesús alma humana him
and soul ayuda a los habitantes a
liberar secretos profundos y acercarse
los unos a los
en su retrato era un quiso evocar a su
país
mi país de origen es burkina faso por
eso hay una bandera con rojo amarillo
verde deje de momentos de reunión para
aprender a conocernos y hablar por eso
me encanta este proyecto
[Música]
michelle quieren ampliar el proyecto y
seguir visibilizando experiencias de
vidas únicas
genial transgresor provocador pero
popular todos estos adjetivos describen
hace a los guns book a 30 años de su
muerte francia le reserva una lluvia de
homenajes muchos lo veneran otros lo
detestan pero lo cierto es que se le
considera un monumento de la canción
francesa y para nuestra crónica cultural
natal y olivares se acercó a su casa en
parís un lugar que mantiene vivo su
recuerdo
[Música]
bienvenidos al distrito 6 de parís hay
frente a lo que fue la casa de sean gays
bug en momentos en que el grupo cuarteto
cubano retoma una de sus canciones más
exitosas una versión bien latina de la
javanaise
[Música]
treinta años después muchos le siguen
rindiendo homenajes con dibujos y
grafitis frente a esta casa que espera
ser algún día un museo se os westwood
nosotros los recordamos con extractos de
sus conciertos
[Música]
todos solo
papaya
pianista de formación señor ganso se
inspiró de las obras maestras se inspiró
de baja se inspiró de sopa también se
inspiró de sus múltiples musas las más
importantes jiang qing o brigitte bardot
inicial bebé es una canción para ella
para la bimbo de los 70 inicial bebé es
una canción directamente inspirada de la
novena sinfonía de euforia
[Música]
[Aplausos]
ella
a cada disco este campo levantaba una
ola de indignación debido a los textos
crudos de sus canciones pero también
debido a sus adicciones al tabaco y al
alcohol yo estube en youtube ya que
remover es una canción que cuenta sus
tumultuosas relaciones amorosas
[Música]
sí
los días que llevamos
insolente y provocador seas gangwon es
clave aquí en francia a pesar de haber
quemado un billete de 500 francos ante
los franceses a pesar de haber adaptado
en versión reggae el himno nacional la
marsellaise a pesar de esto se arriesgó
sigue siendo clave
gracias métele olivares y nos despedimos
con color café desean rock guns bo
muchísimas gracias por su sintonía y
hasta la próxima
no sé qué hacer
[Música]
lloré
te vas
[Música]